no biscuit no it's a sweet
this is only special day in kimberlen's
birthday
it's they give to us gift one kilograms
biscuit and sweet so that is special
[Music]
when i lived in north korea i didn't
know too much about the outside
countries we never seen outside
countries movies we only
watched north koreans movie and kim
family's documentaries
north korea is distribution countries
so everyone is a different amount is
government
gives us food so house wipes 300 grams a
day
and the strength is the same 300 grams
and the high school is 0.3 grams
universities 600 grams and workers
700 or 900 grams when
a mother bringed this rice and she
divided 15 days and also divided
three meals you know that is never
enough to us
so we always hunger but we never
complained
to our family is the parents because
that is a government rules no biscuit no
it's a sweet this is only special day in
kimberlen's
first day is they give to us gift
one kilograms biscuit and sweet
so that is special for early 1990s
government
stopped the sport so people just died of
stabbings
so we usually saw these dead bodies in
the street
and in marketplace or in in upper
areas and every morning we woke up and
we heard that some family died of stuff
in their rooms but in early 1996
though one day is the my uncle's
colleague came to my home and she told
me that
my uncle is very endless when i sold my
uncle i
really shocked because my uncle already
starving but he didn't tell it to us
so look like him his own
skins and bones so he stayed seven days
at home and then he passed away
so when i saw him
i couldn't speak out and my brother also
silent but i really loved my uncle
because it went my parents busy
and he always told to us nighttime
stories
so i really loved him but my lovely
uncle died of stopping in front me
really shocked that times
my head kind of lot of questions
why we respected to them but
why we returned about that is starving
how government solve these problems
but i scared how can i ask to these
questions to government or
some another people so
i also silence too my brother
he didn't say any word but he
also think about the same as me when he
saw
his brother died of stubby and he also
i think his changed mind but last time
is my brother conditions really bad
and he didn't walk so i waited
my condition my brothers if he condition
is better
i want to live to these countries with
my brother and the younger brother too
but my brother is
condition is really bad last time my
brother told me that
you saved your younger brother you leave
this country
i left him alone in cold dining room
and i left only one power rice
and cleaning clothes next to him if
someone
find out to my father give to give to
him
last meal so
me and the younger brother left north
korea
in other times so i still don't know
when my father passed away
and when he was 48
me and my younger brother met near the
chinese border
and we crossed the border it's midnight
to 2 a.m from north korea to
the china that is between this is the
liver is only 25 meter
not too high so it's present so me and
the younger brothers this is run
so we it's a halfway then
we heard that is somebody just shouted
to us stop
stop and they got fired to us but we
already closed
water so we knocked
to house and this is the korean chinese
so he gave to us it's nice meals
it's white rice and also boiled
eggs i'm really surprised because i
thought that
china is really poor countries he told
me that
that is not a safe place because it is
night time is already confirmed in north
korea's side so in the morning
maybe chinese authorities such a distant
place
so you are not saved this place
and after he told me that if you saved
your younger brother you have to marry
chinese man
it's usually in china they both north
korean females
they look like to us sex slavery and
workers we say that if you're not
married chinese one
we contacted two police and you sent
back to north korea
my brother told me that sister you have
to go
i survived myself in here don't worry
so my brother didn't survive
in china he sent back to north korea
so now he's almost 28 with
20 years so i still don't know his
survivor or die and where is
him but i never give up i stay with
my younger brother so what was your life
like with the chinese farmer who bought
you
his mother told me that is
i borrowed a lot of money and bulk to
you
so you can walk outside and paid this
money
i didn't understand 4 30 i a
a.m i woke up and then walk
until the dark days and she gave me only
rice
and kimchi
that's life was really i really hated
me you know that's his slavery life
again in north korea is in china
so some so sometimes i talked about
i wanted to suicide because i didn't
save my younger brother i lost all
families
but one day i found out i was pregnant
nobody had to my delivering child
yes 12 hours i paint and then
i burst my child but i'm very happy
it's my family so when my child
hungry days is a chinese man really
drunk
and he came to home and he took he told
me that
i wanted to sort my child
i just stand up and i holding the knife
if you touched my son i kill you
he's my family he's given me
dreams and he's given me some hopes
five years i stayed in china and last
time
i moved to many many areas because
i can't stay in one areas because they
already know that
and that is really dangerous so i moved
many many areas
it's midnight when i worked in market
and i came to home ten chinese
authorities came home
the really big and fat guys came to my
home
and they arrest me in front my
five years old child my heart is just
speed with and i know that is if
i arrested and sent back to north korea
i this is execute or prison camp
so they handcuffed me
and my child didn't understand what
happened
then he asked me that mommy why did you
abandon me
why you leave me so when i heard these
questions
i didn't say no no no i didn't say
i just cried cried because i didn't
abandon him abundantly but
his five years old child he talked about
that
my mom has abandoned me
so at this point you're sent back into
north korea yes yeah yeah
we first went to the north korea
security prison camp
so in prison that is a small room and
we usually sit between 50 or 60 people
together in noon so we woke up same as
5 a.m and until the 11 p.m
we always always sat down and we
couldn't
move if we removed something that they
also punished to us
supporting females sleep together and we
usually use
totally used toilets in a bucket and the
inside is not
right so one day i found out that my leg
was
problems and i had 39's
temple but they didn't give any
medicines
and the next day my leg was swallowing
then after this
yellow waters came out and many people
told me that that is
smelling is really disgusting these
smellings look like dead bodies smelly
and usually isis is stable because it's
high temperature
they put me is government the places
this place is orphanage
house that is often the houses
government looked for
these places so i stayed these places
three months
but my leg was still the problems i have
to leave
because if i didn't i don't i didn't
leave this country i may be
sent back prison again so you managed to
get away from the government building
where you were being treated
but how did you get back into china with
an injured leg first time i left north
korea in 1998
i didn't read broker i didn't use but in
2004
they have lots of brokers in north korea
so they these brokers usually find out
who
crossed wanted to know china but they
usually
find out the females not the males
because the female is money in china
so i told him i wanted to go china
and he said that human trafficking
so i agreed to him and i knew that is
what means
human trafficking but i have no choice i
had no money
and my condition is really bad but i
hide to him
i didn't tell him my leg was problems
so he accept me and then we cross the
border
broker and me and one females
same as me human trafficking and one old
man
he is binded his relatives in china
so in midnight 2 a.m we
crossed to the tumor neighbor
so when we crossed the border and then
we couldn't walk in
road areas because in china they usually
find out
north koreans because the reasons that
is north korea south this
chinese government paid to them if they
find north koreans
so testimonies really
top these salaries so many chinese
people they don't work
they just only find out the north
koreans that is better than salaries
so we couldn't work is the road areas
we work in mountain areas we find out
taxi we have to taxi we can't walk these
areas
so we vandal taxi and then
on the taxis poor people so taxi driver
on the next two is a north korean broker
and the v3 is in park so driver asked
to us where did you go but north korean
broker
you can't speak chinese and then i
quickly
spoke to him he said the uh address
and then he asked us a lot of questions
you know it's
because this chinese this travel driver
they also is the same spice here
so ask twas lots why he can't
speak so i said he grew up in korea town
and
he didn't graduated high school so
that's why
he can't speak so it's and again is
young lady why i can't speak it's
highness so i told
him she's my sister and she's mute
but she didn't speak you know she also
really scared that time
and the young young this old man is my
father and
he also grew up in korea town and they
can't speak
chinese so but
how did you speak chinese so i said i
graduated high school
so then he also questioned to us that is
really the late times but why you didn't
you are going to somewhere so i
opted today is my trousers and
the show to him is when i walked in
mountain and the
snake fit me so now is we have
went to the hospital so he saw my leg
and that times my leg was
dark purpose then he believed
oh i quickly drive then we arrived at
chinese broken house
and my north korean broker
really angry and then he asked me that
is
what kind of conversations do you it's a
driver
and he already know that his driver's
spy so
i explained everything that and then
they laugh
so i thought that's oh that's his
time then after i told him
i have child in here i wanted to quickly
direct him this call
to him so first day tonight
no no you promised to us human
trafficking in china
then next morning i woke up and it's
it's all it's a young young
already already gone they already
sold to her after korean broker told me
that
you contacted your son just only once
so i quickly tired to his grandma house
and i told to him son is mom
then my son is only one world
mom and he cried
and i cried so room is really
quiet and everyone is hurt my sons cry
and i cried that is really
emotional times then my son awful
and after korean brocco told me that
you saved my life last night i have two
children in north korea
so if you say i they this driver sent to
us
chinese police and then i sent back to
north korea and maybe i went
sent to prison camp but you saved my
life
so this time i saved your life
you have to go when i lived in north
korean prison
i only talked about this survivor and
the united medicine that is
my whole dreams but i made my dreams
and then i met my son that is really
happy moment
i still remember it those times
i wanted to leave to china because
i already knew that china is also
dangerous countries too
2007 i met america korean pastor
in beijing and he sent to us united
nations
and the united nations center to us in
united kingdom so now that you're
reunited with your son
did you move to the uk together yes yeah
with me
did you have any expectations of the
united kingdom before you came
i know england is the histories this man
is always wearing the heart
and the woman is wearing the dresses so
that is think about that is romantic
and maybe different world i thought that
is
england only white people live in
england
but in airport you know totally
different faces
asians africans white people
are really shocked that it first shocked
me
and the second shocked me is newspaper
in north college newspaper is really
important
and that's also politic means but in
england
a lot of newspapers in street and the
people
read newspaper then they put pin
and then top something's queen's
pictures or
it's prime minister pictures but never
cared
so this is oh my god these people maybe
have to go present something that that
is yeah that is the first reason
so what's your life like now oh that is
a new chapter
in here so i'm really happy every day
with families you know my children
always
smile and these happy moments we have
got
dinner times you know children go to
school and come back
home they talked about the school life
and
they planned something that we always
they said
smile that is really hard big big happy
moment
because in north korea we are family but
we didn't know that
is what means family and what means
happy
so that is really thankful to uk
people to accept to us in here so now is
i am new life when you look back at
north korea
what do you think about it
i never think but i only saw the
memories
in north korea that is still the pimple
because that is not a history that is
real life
you know 75 years dictatorship continued
in north korea and the
huge concentration camps and the people
laughing slavery people still speak
about the holocaust in the second world
war
but this north korea is still to happen
concentration camps
and they divided our people into their
lives
so i always think about these people
these people also they had dreams
a lot of people who have tourette's tend
to report that they have fewer ticks or
none during sex
but the thing about that is that's
because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex um
which is really [ __ ] brutal
because i've never hurt a guy's ego more
than simply going
during an intimate moment